Hey,
what's going on as bill burn?
It's time for the Thursday afternoon,
Monday morning podcast just before Friday.
And
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you so you know your week's going.
Oh,
it's Thursday.
You know somebody gave me shit the other day.
Fucking talking about how you don't always say Thursday.
It's payday.
Like,
oh couldn't fuck a job.
Did you?
Where were you?
Good bye.
Always got paid on Friday.
I always get paid on Thursday.
Whatever.
So you either getting your money today,
you're getting it tomorrow,
right?
We all know you're going to be broke by Tuesday,
Wednesday walking around.
You know what your brown bag,
you got to bring a fucking lunch cause you got no money for fucking
to go out to the roach coach.
Hey,
you packed a lunch aid on front.
Eat healthy.
You're broke,
aren't you?
Yeah.
Um,
I can't believe the fucking money I used to blow when I was a kid.
I used to make 260 bucks a week,
right?
My only expense.
I had a car payment,
130 $838 and 62 cents I still remember it.
And uh,
that was it.
And gas that was making 260 bucks.
And I was,
that was my take home,
260 bucks a week.
Right.
So what's that?
860 times four is two 40 hours a week over grand a month.
Then I'd be fucking broke every Wednesday.
Fucking idiot.
I swear to God.
If I was a miser,
I might as well have been a miser.
This what the fuck I should have done.
Okay.
Tell him he was going out in the clubs and crushing it.
Coming out with my fucking orange Afro.
Hey ladies.
I mean it was a shit show.
It was Charlie Brown trying to kick the football.
It was like Atlanta trying to win a champion job.
Come on bill.
Come on.
The new Cleveland Ladies and gentlemen,
all of a sudden Cleveland wins a fucking basketball championship and the entire
countries and kill the cubs won.
How nervous were you down there in La and Atlanta?
You know what I mean?
Atlanta,
I can't even say it this morning.
Atlanta.
How fucking nervous were you?
Cleveland wins.
You're like,
Oh shit,
all we got left the cubs,
you know,
maybe if the Indians were,
and then they went to champions.
Cleveland winds two championships in a year.
The cubs is still the fucking sad sacks and like 108 years or whatever.
And then they went three in a row.
The cubs winning alien tires,
sporting world just stops,
turns around and stares at Atlanta Quiver and over in the corner.
Like,
hey guys,
you know,
for the record,
the Braves one at 95
it's got to count for something.
Right?
Oh,
those poor bastards.
You know,
I just connected in a,
I connected in with the fuck was I in,
I'm in Atlanta and I saw this woman walking by and she had on a falcons hat and
I was like,
you know what,
good for,
there's a real fan still wearing the Atlanta shit.
Right?
And it was a red hat.
But then I also noticed that she was wearing red sneakers,
you know what I mean?
And she,
then,
she was also African American.
And I was just,
and I just assumed she didn't give a fuck.
I learned that from Patrice O'neil the first time I saw him with like an
islanders had on,
right.
I was like,
aw,
fuck man,
you liked the islanders.
He was like,
what?
I go,
you liked the islanders.
And he took off his hat and looked at it goes,
Nah,
man,
don't give a shit.
I go,
he goes,
I just liked the colors.
He had these pair of fucking,
I only is covered colored shoes,
sneakers on.
He told me,
say,
Bill,
black people don't give a fuck about,
I mean,
I might say Jamaica,
you know,
here we go.
The white guy.
I got to fucking make sure I fucking say this correctly.
He was saying,
generally speaking,
we were the shit because of colors.
It's not neat,
you know?
And he joked,
he just fuck it.
Yeah.
He trashed me all the fucking time.
So anyway,
so I looked at her and I did that.
Patrice conversation just popped into my fucking head and I was just like,
as she probably just thought we just needed a hat to go with those fucking shoes
as opposed to white people were the same fucking hat forever.
It's all frayed and shit.
Walking around with your cargo pants and your flip flops.
I don't think I'll ever get over fucking northern Florida.
I know,
I've heard a zillion jokes about it,
but Jesus fucking Christ,
Jesus fucking Christ,
there are some characters out there.
Okay.
And what's amazing is it's absolutely gorgeous.
And then there's people with like beautiful homes in money,
but they're there.
I swear to God,
is it me?
There's no middle class.
It's like when you go to a third world country,
it's just like this,
just fucking people living in this crazy poverty and then they'll just be,
there's a mansion.
I Dunno.
Anyway,
well,
you know,
probably didn't help that I fucking went to the Daytona 500 bunch of Yahoos like
me.
And by the way,
I fit right in.
I fucking fit right in the,
I'm,
you know,
I dunno,
I should be more white collar.
But,
uh,
due to some financial reasons,
I had a very fucking,
yeah,
I'm,
I'm pretty much a put it this way.
I,
it was,
it wasn't until he hung around with a bunch of a poetry stories here.
I wasn't telling hung up with Patrice that I realized that macaroni and cheese
wasn't a main dish.
We,
you Sam,
all of that shit,
macaroni and cheese with toast was a meal and I fucking loved it.
Get half a tray just scooping that shit out was a craft.
I've told you to talk to you guys about this chicken Alec King on toast.
Chipped beef on toast.
I fucking hated that shit.
Chicken out of the king was also gross.
Um,
those are the,
yeah.
You know,
in mother's fucking work and she comes home,
she's got 90 kids,
opens up a couple of cans,
throws it in the pot and make some toast.
Fucking animals.
Um,
anyways.
Okay.
Chef Boyardee
you know,
when I think back to this is important that we,
we didn't know anything about fucking nutrition back then.
TV.
We weren't never really big on the TV dinners.
And I remember I used to ask my mother to get him.
I just think that there was something,
I don't what the fuck was called Hungry Jack's or some shit.
Something.
I had jack in it.
It sounded manly.
You know the commercials is all,
you know,
big chunks in Turkey with gravy,
mashed potatoes and I was sitting there going,
Alice looks,
that looks fucking delicious.
Okay.
I Dunno.
We just never,
we never,
we weren't,
we didn't,
we didn't cross that line with the fast food.
You know,
I'm a mistake.
And so those were my favorites.
I'd be sitting and I would be sitting not paying attention in the last three
periods of school when I was in a middle school,
junior high,
whatever the fuck you call it,
just thinking about the stake of note I was going to make when I got home.
That's all I gave a fellow.
That was a game changer.
You know,
kid from the seventies eighties you know,
he came home,
your parents weren't home,
right.
Latch key kid,
you come home.
The game changer was when you went from making something just room temperature
or cold to actually getting the,
you know,
the next level.
It's like moving up and like a,
you know,
army ranks is Scientology,
whatever.
We get to a new level of security clearance.
Okay.
You can use the fucking frying pan and all of a sudden you had a fucking hot
meal.
I used to cook those fuckers up,
put them on white bread and then you had to eat it real quick because the
grease,
there was so much fucking Greece from whatever cut of meat.
Was it squirrel?
I didn't know what the fuck it was.
It was such a shit cut up meat that the grease would just be coming through the
bread.
It was,
it was fucking gross push.
You put ketchup on it and shit.
Sorry if I'm grossing.
Yeah,
let me get off the subject.
Uh Oh,
I gotta.
I got dress all the fucking who and whom police.
Oh my God.
That's like a whole cult within itself.
The level of fucking arrogance that people came and the joy that they had that
I,
that I'm not good at who and home you would think that you could actually make
money off of that.
Like they had a hot stock tip,
but some shit,
hey,
this fucking company is going to go public.
He didn't hear from me.
This is one thing that I learned.
I think I finally figured out,
because people told me this trick before,
it's like if you could substitute he or she use who you know him or her use
home,
so I'm like,
to whom do I have the pleasure of speaking to and I'm like to him,
I have the pleasure.
Yeah,
of speaking with.
I wouldn't say that.
That's what,
that doesn't work too.
She do.
I have the pleasure of speaking.
Yeah,
like I don't fucking get it,
but then it's like,
no,
who are you speaking to?
You would say to him,
to her.
Then I was like,
oh,
that's what they mean.
I thought the,
I thought you just meant take out who are home and plug in.
He or she
who did this shit,
he did this shit.
I get it.
I think I just got it.
I think I finally cracked the fucking code.
But here's the deal with who and what's the deal.
Here's the deal with that shit.
Nobody says whom out loud unless you teaching an English class.
No one says that.
Right?
It's always who,
who the fuck do I?
You know?
Okay.
It's not.
To whom am I speaking was like,
who the fuck am I talking to?
Oh,
the fuck are you
to home?
Am I fucking speaking with?
Yeah.
You speaking to fucking him.
That's why you said fuck it home.
Oh,
right.
Thanks Jerry.
Nobody says it out loud,
but it's one of those things if you,
if you don't write it correctly,
yeah.
People flipped the fuck out and they judge you like you're a fucking moron.
But I've never heard anybody,
you know,
that's,
that's another one that's,
that's another like security level.
You go past.
If you start out loud using the not not writing.
Okay.
Speaking and you use the word whom like you've alienated probably 80% of the
population of my country.
And I don't think that there's a bigger example of the gap between wealth and
regular people then using whom in public.
I always picture that.
I
know,
you know something even that cause there's people that fucking rob and steal
their way into the upper 1% and then they just a fucking dope like me still.
But if you're born,
if you're born into that shit,
if you get some trust fund hanging over your head,
if you're one of those kids and you have to learn how to fence,
take a fencing fucking class in college to show that you're a gentlemen,
you know,
do you walk around to you date rape drug in your pocket?
Does your dad knows a judge and can get you off and you wear loafers with no
socks,
right?
There's a bunch of stereotypes.
Um,
I was speaking to that me and he had gotten this fucking monster debate last
night.
She take this show,
she goes,
Hey,
I take this show.
It's about rappers in Paris.
You know,
you ought to check this out.
So I was like,
all right,
I'm going to watch this shit.
Right.
So immediately this show when these guys,
and they're rapping and French,
I don't know what say it.
So you know,
I'm trying to read the words.
I'm a dope.
It's going by too fast.
But it sounds a lot like,
you know,
it's the same sort of point of view as a lot of rappers over here,
which I am in a the minority group.
I'm getting treated like shit.
I'm living in the shittiest part of the fucking city.
A lot of that stuff.
Right.
But it's flying by because I can't read fast enough.
So they got this fucking nerdy white kid goes to interview this dude,
um,
who's Muslim and he's living in some part in Paris.
Right.
And he's talking about all of this stuff that's happening to them now.
And uh,
no,
the first thing you talked about,
he said that he was talking about how um,
he said thank God that he found,
you know,
rap and he did that,
cause you know,
he could've gone the other way.
He said,
I could've become a bomb.
That's what he said.
So the white dude goes like,
oh,
you mean like,
you know,
you would have blown some people up or something like that.
And then the dude's basically like,
I knew you were going to take it that way.
That's not how I meant it.
That's really offensive.
And I,
you know,
and he's speaking through an interpreter,
tell him if he's going to come down here and talk to people,
he needs to check the way he's talking to people,
blah,
blah.
And I'm just sitting there going like,
you totally set him up for that.
That was like fucking a trap.
But what do you think?
He's going to think?
So Nia goes,
well,
he's not doing that.
Okay.
So you know,
he gets judged because of those actions of the few of the few.
And it's just like,
I understand that.
I totally understand that.
But at some point you have to address the fucking elephant in the room,
don't you?
You know?
Yeah.
Like when people,
like when I travel outside of this country and people treat me like shit because
I'm an American,
I don't act like that just fell out of the sky.
I know where that's coming from.
The appear realistic way that we've colonized the entire fucking world.
The amount of time we've,
we've sided with dictators because they've given us fucking oil.
Is there a Preston their own PD?
The amount of times we've been on the wrong fucking side of shit.
It's like Anna walk around like,
well,
I didn't do it.
It's like,
you know,
as much as it's still wrong to judge me,
I understand that when I walk out of the House,
I'm no longer me anymore.
It's teams.
It's like red sox and Yankees.
Okay.
And you're,
and you're fucking the hat,
the team hat you're wearing is you skin.
Okay.
And people are going to judge you for that.
You know,
back when I had here and I came walking down the street looking like fucking
Richie Cunningham,
you know,
I knew that people were looking at me like that.
You know,
like fuck it dude,
dude dude didn't do and I can take this kid's lunch money.
Look at his fucking hair
doesn't make it right.
Absolutely does not make it right but like to sit there and act like you don't
know where shit is coming from.
That's what drives me nuts.
And it's like I completely understand that on my side to have empathy for that
guy.
But what was pissing me off was there was no empathy coming from the other side
being like,
listen,
I understand.
You know,
cause there was no understanding of that,
that wrapper that this guy is totally on the outside looking in.
So he's going to come from this fear based fucking thing that he,
you know,
from the shift that he sees in the media and the media is basically you get
judged all groups of people,
you get judged by the Jerry Springer fucking group of your people.
That's basically it.
So with white people were either living in a trailer,
fucking our sister,
or were these lizard people shape shifters that live under a fucking mountain.
Illuminati is essentially it,
right?
There's a law,
there's a zillion of them were wearing a fucking hate group.
We're in the fucking Klan.
We,
yeah,
we got a four wheeler with shooting a gun or whatever.
Right?
And you got all those fucking stereotypes,
um,
which obviously is not a fair fucking thing.
And I also understand that despite those stereotypes,
the Matrix is made for white people.
So I,
despite those,
it really doesn't affect my life and I get all of that type of shit.
But I mean,
I don't know,
I just needed that guy in the moment to just be like,
you know what?
I understand why you said that.
You know,
rather than just immediately go into lecture mode because then when you're
sitting at home,
I don't know if you're like me,
I just plugged myself in.
Well,
who would I be in that scenario?
I'd be that guy getting a lecture.
So I just started saying all this shit.
I would've said back to him and it drove my fucking wife up the wall.
She's like,
why can't you just watch things?
It's like,
you know,
what do you mean,
why can't I,
the TV's interacted to me the same shit I do when I watch wheel of fortune and I
make fun of every contestant and you sitting there laughing your ass off and I
turned it into this like a comedy show.
You then get mad at me when I do the same fucking thing when I'm watching this
other shit.
And so we just made a truce.
It's like,
don't,
I don't want to watch any,
any shit with you that has to do with this stuff
because we're going to end up in a fucking argument because I'm going to act
like I'm watching wheel of fortune.
Um,
anyways,
why is this thing bing bang in Bowman and all that type of shit.
You know,
having said all that,
I completely understood where that guy was coming from.
It's like,
yeah,
I didn't do any of that shit.
You know,
I'm trying to get the fuck outta here.
I've lived in this country my whole life and I never felt like it was mine.
Okay.
Which is,
you know,
and this is the arrogant thing that I'm going to do,
not even living over there.
I'm going to chastise white people like,
cause we do it here.
You can't do that to people.
You can't have people living in the country their whole fucking lives and the
hour American,
they are French and all that.
You cannot treat them like,
yeah,
but you know,
you know,
you're not real American American.
It's like,
well fucking neither were you then you're European or whatever the fuck you're
from.
Um,
so I don't,
I'm not,
I'm not a fucking,
I like to think I'm not a fucking bad guy.
I get all of that type of shit.
But Jesus Christ at some point,
you know,
like I,
I used to joke right after nine 11 and they started racially profiling Arabs and
all that,
which was completely fucked up.
And I understood it,
but I never heard it.
Like I just always looked at it like,
all right,
if 20 redheads knocked down some skyscrapers,
you know,
I'd expect to be getting some looks the next day at the airport.
Does it make it right?
But I wouldn't be sitting there going up.
I completely understand where this is coming from and I don't like it because
I'm an innocent guy,
but I would have the empathy to at least address where the fear is coming from.
And it's,
I think that if you just fucking do that,
the other side can just relax and maybe listen to your point.
Okay.
You know,
because that's what happened to me when I watched that and I watched that kid
all of a sudden get a lecture after that guy said I'd turned my s I could've
become a bomb.
And I just felt he set the fucking kid up and then I immediately went into
defense mode defending that kid and I knew and I didn't even at that point sit
and listen to what this guy had to say.
So then I didn't learn anything.
Okay.
I would equate that to like,
you know,
when people make,
try to make a point,
like when people are trying to teach me who and whom.
So much of it started with,
hey fuck head,
maybe you should try Bubbleq um,
how do I get past?
Hey fuck it.
I don't know.
I like to think that there was a decent point made in there.
I'm sure I'll get a bunch of shit for that.
But um,
either way,
it was an interesting debate,
you know,
hey,
I bought those fucking Boston Celtics upbeat,
the Cleveland Cavaliers,
what God's name is a cavalier.
There's probably some fucking fancy name for white oppressor.
Wait a second,
Kev.
I know you can act cavalier cavalier attitude.
Can you ever have a cavalier attitude and it's like a fucking,
like a good thing.
Cavalier is like,
that's like a happy go lucky upper 1% or you know what I mean?
Like if they were broke,
they'd be,
they'd be oop Taylor with the fucking stick over their shoulder with the little
little fish hook on it.
You know,
just going to go skip some rocks.
But all of a sudden,
you know,
if you cavalier and you're in the upper 1% is a white dude.
That means a,
I dunno,
it's a bunch of kids digging for fucking,
um,
diamonds.
I don't fucking,
let me look at this.
Okay hottie disdainful.
I,
cause I was Ron Hardy,
disdainful
or supercilious.
I don't know what that word is.
An arrogant and cavalier attitude towards other offhand
Cleveland Cavaliers.
He's,
is it anything,
it's gotta be something else.
Yeah.
Are they really the Cleveland arrogant constants?
I would think they named themselves.
It can't be,
that's it's to a horseman.
There it is.
Especially a mounted soldier a night.
Yeah.
Oppressive,
oppressive wire.
White Guy.
Uh,
one having this spirit or bearing of a night,
a courtly gentleman Galleon,
these guys are arrogant.
Huh?
A man escorting a woman or acting as their partner in dancing.
All right.
We're slowly getting to the NBA lifestyle here.
They're coming out of the shower and all the horrors hanging out,
waiting to get him his fucking magic.
Johnson used to say,
you've got chastised for that.
These women,
they're out to get you after the show.
Oh,
that's offensive to women,
not the horse.
That's who I was talking about.
Sweetheart,
go back to your soccer mom cave with your red wine.
Thank you.
Um,
in the okay.
And adherent of an adherent of Charles,
the first of England and his contest with the problem.
It's amazing that I speak this language and there's so many words that I've just
never seen before and have no idea how to pronounce.
All right.
As an adjective hottie disdainful.
And that's super Cylus.
Whatever the fuck that is offhand,
that's a good name for a fucking dance.
Like when those meatpacking district dance clubs,
I got to go down in the SIF has fell off last night.
I'm [inaudible] girlfriend totally fucking now.
And their parents like,
I'm not against you.
I don't have to transplant all right offhand or unceremonious
of or relating to the Cavaliers.
But that's a fucking lazy definition of relating to a characteristic of the
cavalier poets or their work or I don't know what a cavalier is.
This is either a gentlemen a night,
a poet,
or a cunt.
You know,
one of the other,
I guess it depends if you live in Cleveland or not.
They probably think they're a bunch of gentlemen.
They're not yet at animals.
Oh,
those.
That's a special kind of animal that lives up there in Cleveland.
You know what I mean?
You know why that Lake caught on fire?
It wasn't the lake.
It was very,
you know what it was because so many of those animals walked into at bay.
That's what happened.
They took that beautiful water that God may and they turned it into something
flammable.
I'm just kidding.
Yeah.
They always say the mistake by the lake and they always say that Lake Erie
caught on fire.
It didn't catch on fire.
It was,
it was way more understandable.
It was like a,
I think it was a whatever the,
the runoff,
they went into the city and they were just dumping all their pollution into it.
They didn't light a great lake on fire.
Um,
yeah.
I don't know.
But now with all that fracking,
the fracking down the road,
shit,
I go to get my God damn above ground pool.
Next thing you know I'm having a fucking,
except I'm the main course.
So are we understand that a,
you are upset,
but we don't feel that our company has anything to do with your above ground
pool catching on fire.
Oh fuck you and your soup.
Um,
all right,
let's read some advertising here for this week.
Dirty Lemon.
It sounds the only stupid fucking jokes and the dirty Sanchez.
You know those fucking joke book jokes and everybody seems to love for fucking
me.
And it's when you fucking take a piece of road beef,
slap her in the tent,
then you come on her foot.
Oh,
is that what it's called?
Doing those jokes.
He's got called the get the fuck outta here.
Cause I don't wanna hear any more of these stupid he'd get rid of.
He moved it
to rub one out and just fucking relax with your knock.
Knock Dick Jokes.
All right.
Dirty Lemon.
Dirty lemon is a wellness beverage brand featuring ingredients that have been
well established in the,
Oh God.
Here's another English word.
I can say a nat,
nat natural pathic community nature pathic
naturopathic
knit Toora paddock.
Anyway,
so there's three types of these fucking things right now.
Sleep,
detox in skin plus hair.
Oh Shit.
I might get some of this.
And each one contains the juice of one lemon,
no sugar,
and it's under 10 calories.
I have no idea what the fuck this stuff is.
Their sleep drink,
for example,
includes magnesium.
Was there anything grosser than milk of magnesium when you were a kid?
You meet some milk of magnesium.
It came in that blue bottle.
Yeah.
What was I supposed to do?
Coat your esophagus.
Was that for a fucking sword?
Swallower um,
put me in a lot of that backstage at the circus and he should,
one contains the juice of one lemon.
No sugar is under 10 calories.
They're asleep.
Drink for example,
includes magnesium rosewater and camel meal,
which all help you sleep better.
Evidently I drank one the other night before bed and I slept like a bear.
Okay.
Why?
Why wouldn't you send me this product first?
And I would,
uh,
say something about better dreams.
Oh,
okay.
So when I didn't drink this thing and I slept like a bear,
I had this fucking amazing dream that,
uh,
I don't know.
Pick one of these fucking starlets was fucking ride my dick.
And the detox is secretly great hangover cure.
Oh,
now you in my wheelhouse.
Drink a bottle and the activated charcoal absorbs toxins in your body.
I would like a 12 pack of that police.
But the best part about dirty lemon is that the only way to order is via text
message.
You'll never find it in stores.
Jesus Christ.
This is some underground shit to order.
Go to dirty lemon.com.
Register your mobile number,
then send them a text message.
Say it,
I'll do a real human.
And after a few texts,
as six pack is sent to your door in one to two days,
once you buy via texts,
you'll never want to go back.
When you text them,
mention your hurt.
I'm going to fucking get some of this shit and I'm going to go out and I'm going
to drink a bunch of fucking Tequila or some shit.
And I'm gonna do is I'm going to see if it works.
That'd be great.
Sitting here with a fucking wife and a beautiful baby,
you know,
need giving me shit for getting drunk.
It's like,
Nah,
I'm researching a product.
Um,
when you text them,
mentioned you heard about it on my podcast and they'll throw in an extra case of
the sleep drink for free with your first or at 12 bottles for the price as six.
For more information,
check out dirty lemon.com for other morons out there.
Lemon is spelled l.
Not UN Lemon.
Lemon.
All right,
come on.
You guys are a bunch of drugs like me,
aren't you?
When she like a little charcoal and you're fucking cess Barilla there.
Alright,
distilled genes.
Great genes don't have to be complicated.
Whereas the Zipper,
if you're not into crazy stitching,
diamonds are embedded stud.
You're not alone.
Oh yeah,
I remember those true religion jeans.
Jesus Christ.
There's so many people that got those and knocked up a chicken and now dad's
pushing strollers around those fucking true religion jeans with the Stitch Torsh
shoe on the fucking ass pockets.
And then the lining down this side.
Yeah,
that's standing.
That's pushing somebody on a swing right now.
I'll frayed at the bottom.
MMM.
Distill genes pronounced is stilled,
offers luxury grade denim at an affordable price.
Jeans that would normally cost you hundreds distilled start at just 75 bucks.
These are great jeans.
I've actually tried these on.
I enjoyed them.
They felt great around my balls and sec area.
Um,
they utilize the same fabrics,
factories,
and wash houses as the best known brands and designers who works in those
places.
Where do you work?
I work in a denim wash house.
Yeah.
I make 30 cents a day,
uh,
while skipping the markups and middlemen the result.
Pure,
unadulterated denim without the retail run around.
Just go to distill.com spelled DST LD,
mmm.
Delta Sierra,
Tango Lima,
delta.com and see where minimalist design meets maximum comfort.
They guarantee the fit.
They'll ship them to you for free.
It give you,
give you free returns,
grouse you'll find after you sweat them up,
sweat up and fucking cross country flight.
You can send it back.
They don't care until you find.
The perfect pair of distilled has been featured in Forbes time and tech crunch
as well as on denim clad celebrities in Gq and vogue distilled is the only place
in the u s you can get this quality,
this quality of denim for this price.
You can find their amazing selection of outerwear,
leather jackets and tee shirts to go on Rob Halford here and more and using some
of the same principles of high grade materials at low end costs.
Even celebrities are wearing distilled.
We're not going to name any,
we're just going to throw that out there.
I've got a pair.
Oh,
I guess I'm supposed to be talking to one myself.
I've got a pair of the,
I don't know what style it is.
They fit perfect.
They were a little long in the leg,
but I,
you know,
what are you going to do?
There's still does your answer to elevate to elevated style without elevated
prices.
Just Jesus fucking Christ.
Let's get to the end here.
Just go to [inaudible] dot com slash bar right now and get 10% off your first
pair.
That's distilled.com d,
s t e l d m.com/birth for 10% off right now.
Five letters,
Delta,
Sierra,
tango,
Lima,
delta.com/.
Bar.
How many fucking more?
Oh Jesus.
Two more.
Hang in there.
Oh,
but oh,
popo.
Mandy's me undies.
Walk around in my jeans,
but do,
do,
do me undies.
Me,
Andy's,
my balls are dry,
if you know what I mean.
I put that cotton,
they'll put the modal up on my tape by balls or dry.
Uh,
don't say they ain't.
I always say that and have fucking taint.
What else?
Ryan's with tank.
Um,
taint eight saint of,
there you go.
Put that modal up against my tape.
The Catholic Church just made me a say because I love the other way as they
bagged a kid.
Nobody gives a fuck.
It wasn't all of them.
How can you still go there?
Right?
Uh,
me undies.
Elevate the underwear game to the next level with me.
Undies.
You've perfected your wardrobe.
You even have a fucking Cape.
But what about the stuff?
Not everybody gets to see if you've been settling for store bought underwear.
Five packs.
I have something that will change your life for bed for the better me undies.
What's the first thing you put on the last thing you take off?
It's your underwear.
Unless you Matthew mcconaughey.
He doesn't wear it,
Rhonda.
Where it all right.
All right.
This comes in with his dick hanging out.
Make your most important piece of clothing the best it can be with me undies.
Mian he's are designed in La and made from sustainable sources.
Micro,
micro,
modal,
modal.
They fucking Dick Dick.
Cutting it up,
man.
Okay.
The fabric three times softer than cotton.
Biondi softer than soft lugs.
I undies.
Is this supposed to be luxury?
Luxury undies come in an ever changing selection of classic colors,
bold shapes and adventurous patterns so you can tailor your undies to your own
personal style.
Guess what?
You can save time and more money money each month with a monthly subscription.
And if you're not ready for a subscription subscription,
that's okay.
You can still say that's because Mandy's is offering you 20% off your first
pair.
Just use our special URL,
[inaudible] dot com slash burn get 20% off first pair.
So go ahead revamp your underwear drawer.
You deserve it.
Once again,
that's [inaudible] dot com slash Burmese dodge com slash burr lastly,
but not leastly.
And after this I'll talk about fucking Aaron Kaufman leaving gas monkey garage.
Cause I know there's a lot of you watch that show like me.
Okay.
Alright.
Oh legal zoom,
everybody.
National small business month@legalzoom.com is here and it's timing.
Couldn't be any
bad.
Approval rates for business loans are up and so it was consumer confidence but
it takes a lot more than good timing to launch a successful business.
That's why legal zoom created a free business startup kit.
Part of being an entrepreneur uses is utilizing the right resources to help you
succeed.
Oh,
I thought it was listed to a broke ass.
People give you great ideas and then you say you don't like it on shark tank,
and then you secretly do it around on their back or you buy it for way less than
you should have paid him.
Isn't that an I own it?
I own the patent.
Uh,
you can't be an expert at everything.
So go to legalzoom.com startup today and download your free sat up kit.
You'll get an educational ebooks and legal zoom discounts to save money setting
up your business.
Plus you can save thousands of dollars through legal zooms partners to offer
offers to help with financing,
marketing,
and day to day operations things you'll need to run a successful business.
Legal Zoom is not a law firm,
but they're dedicated to making life easier for business owners.
Whether you're thinking of starting a business or already run one,
go to legal zoom.com/startup during national small business month.
Ma Ma Ma,
take advantage of your free business startup kit.
That's legal zoom.com/startup ah,
right.
Hey,
by the way,
I,
I actually filmed a bunch of shit at Daytona Five Daytona 500 I filmed some
stuff when I was in Gainesville,
Georgia.
I uploaded it.
I sent it to my podcast guy who's now going to edit it.
I'm actually going to follow through and we should have a couple of videos for
you on my,
on my new fucking youtube page,
youtube.com/user/monday morning podcast.
Once again,
www.youtube.com/users/monday morning podcast.
I'm going to start doing those city tours again.
I'm going to make little stupid videos.
I'm going to get that fucking thing going.
Speaking of which,
I'm going to be in Phoenix this week,
Monday,
Tuesday and Wednesday,
flying in Sunday night to see the fucking Celtics,
Isaiah Thomas.
I'm against the Phoenix Suns there on Sunday night.
I'll see you guys at the game.
Um,
oh,
I'd also like to thank uh,
some people at the Tampa Bay lightening for hooking mean forest shop with some
tickets.
We got to see a Nikita coop giraffe get a hat trick against the auto was
senators.
There was a great fucking game,
great fucking game.
You know,
Tampa,
Tampa Bay came out and it was like they will fucking owning them and then all of
a sudden auto what goes,
hey,
easy.
They're easy.
They're,
and then they took control of the game and then after the fucking,
the first intermission,
I don't know what,
I don't know what sort of a third time adjustments that they used.
It's not half time for all you non hockey fans who tried to say that there's two
halftime's in hockey,
you know that always makes me feel smart.
I'm like,
mathematically that doesn't make sense.
There's a third and then there's two thirds through the game and if you ever
played pickup hockey three on fucking three,
if you've ever fucking done that and you look any,
there's no substitutions.
You know why you would know why they take two breaks.
Okay.
Yeah.
Then I fucking lolly gagging around like a bunch of baseball players and they
just need to stretch once every seven 30 very sprinting.
Someone could beat the shit out of you and just sit down for five minutes.
Okay.
You're going to need to take a couple of breaks.
All right,
let's talk gas monkey garage.
MMM.
Uh,
Monday night's episode was the episode that they've been teasing the whole,
the whole fucking season.
The shit that you read about on social media before the season even started.
The bearded wonder Aaron Kaufman came back from vacation.
Yeah.
He fucking just,
he's straight up quit.
It wasn't,
he didn't give notice.
Say I'll help you on a couple of builds.
He was just like,
I am out.
It's been a great run.
I'll fucking see you later.
And uh,
can Richard Rollins as always was hilarious.
It's like,
I feel like I'm gonna Puke.
Yes.
Can you go?
Oh,
he's only said that a few times during the series and it's always fucking
hilarious cause I feel like the word puke is kind of,
that's like from my generation.
Like he graduated the high school the same year.
I watched the show a lot.
I'm not a psycho,
but he even mentions all the time he built that fucking,
that mercury comet.
You mentioned that he graduated high school in 87 and,
uh,
I should have graduated in [inaudible] 86 but we're not going to talk white.
Why I didn't because I'm a cause you cause you're hurt because you hear me read
out loud.
It should have happened in 86 it was,
I think I'm a year older than him,
but Puca just feel like nobody says that.
I never hear it.
I don't hear it enough.
And he's only said it a couple times.
He said it la,
uh,
on Monday when Aaron quit feel like going to puke.
And he said it when he bought that Ferrari that had been in that major accident
and it was like,
he's big,
this giant investment,
like 300 grand.
He went in with the other,
the fucking rich dude up the street and Lex,
all the European stuff.
I don't know why.
I can't remember his name.
I only seen him and fucking 9,000 episodes and afterwards he was just,
he was so fucking nervous.
He was talking about,
cause I feel like I'm gonna Puke.
I Dunno why.
It always makes me laugh.
So anyways,
um,
okay.
As a fan of the show,
you know,
it was like watching van Halen breakup.
It's like,
oh fuck,
now they're going to bring in,
you know,
some other guy who wasn't David Lee Roth,
not shitting on Hagar,
you know,
I'm just saying,
you know what I mean,
you like the [inaudible] the original guys.
So I was actually happy that they stay for the rest of the episode.
So they was showing Aaron at his house and he was doing this build.
It was fucking hilarious and everything fit engine went in,
transmission,
everything fucking winded fine.
Um,
and then he just got up and took a break and went over and was feeding his
horses and I'm just like,
oh,
there you go.
Although when he was,
you know,
he was trying to make this race car and he was taking all this shit out,
that they don't need so he can make it lighter,
watching him have to do that by himself.
I bet that kind of sucked.
But,
um,
I'm just hoping as a fan that Aaron gets his own shows because I'd read a really
good interview and it wasn't all this he said,
she said Shit,
it just seemed like he wanted to do more adventure is builds of cars that,
you know,
when you're not on a TV show,
you know what I mean?
You're kind of under the constraint.
He was just saying how fast they will build cars,
kind of limited what they could do.
And a,
I think that that was probably the reason why he left.
Just got a little burnt out or whatever.
But,
um,
okay.
It's fucking brutal man.
I mean that was the guy.
So we'll see what happens.
But
I have faith,
I have faith that they're going to find someone to replace him and I'm hoping
that I'm going to get two shows out of it.
Yeah.
MMM.
I Dunno,
but whatever.
It's definitely the end of,
of a Goddamn era.
And,
uh,
I'm trying to think of my,
my favorite builds that they've done on that show.
Um,
I always liked the random shit that they did.
Like,
I've mentioned this before,
I love when they did that low rider and I don't,
can't remember if it was one of those like a 85 Oldsmobile cutlass or something.
I love that they just gave Casey a chance to fucking show off what he could do.
And he was showing all that different kind of,
instead of just painting it black or green.
Um,
but I understand that they always say,
you know,
those are the two colors that sell and you got to make you fucking money.
But um,
there was another time they built this car,
can't remember what it was and it was this white car and on top Casey did this
lace thing on the hood and I'm gonna sorry on the roof.
I fucking love that.
Um,
then they have a fucking Lincoln Continental.
I've always loved the random shit as opposed to the,
uh,
the more obvious stuff.
I love that fucking mercury comment that they made,
although I got to tell you,
I like the fucking white and blue color scheme better when they first had it and
I liked those rims better.
But if they just did all the gas monkey shit underneath it and slammed it down
to the ground,
that's a fucking killer car.
I don't know.
I like weird shit.
Um,
and my biggest heartbreak on that show was one time when Richard Rollins blot
that fucking cab over engine truck,
that jeepers creepers truck.
And I was like,
oh my God,
what the are they going to do to this?
And then he just,
somebody came in like,
the next day I'll give you an extra two grand for,
he's like,
I fucking get outta here.
And I was just like,
what the Huh?
I want to see them build more trucks.
I hope they do.
Um,
all right.
That's it.
Uh,
so good luck to Aaron Kaufman.
I hope I see him on another TV show.
Whatever I should give a shout out to is,
um,
he's got,
he has his own,
he's got his own,
uh,
um,
company that gets it,
builds parts for,
believe it or not,
Ford f 100 hundreds.
What?
I have 68 FordF 100,
and I believe it's called,
I think it's called arc light.
Just look up Aaron Kaufman,
arc light,
and you'll actually find that article.
I should put a link to it.
It's a really good article about,
um,
why he left the show.
And I thought I was happy that it wasn't a bunch of mudslinging or anything like
that.
It just seemed like it was time and he wanted to go in a different direction.
So,
so that's it.
That is the podcast for this fuck and weak.
Um,
no it isn't.
This is just me checking in on you.
I'll do the real podcast on Monday.
This is not a real podcast.
All right.
That's it.
Go fuck yourselves.
Have a great weekend.
You've constant joy the music.
And he was doing an extra half hour of greatest hits from a podcast and a
fucking Monday gone by.
Wow.
So anyways,
I went up to see some family over the 4th of July to celebrate the birthday of
this country.
And,
um,
as I'm driving up,
okay,
I'm listening on the radio and evidently I looked up the song on,
uh,
on the Internet.
It's a Carrie Underwood song,
who I don't,
I don't know what she has.
I'm guessing she's white cause it sounded country and she had little Twang in
her voice,
but I don't want to piss off any Koreans out there.
She might've been Korean,
um,
as a song called before he cheats.
So I'm driving a log and you know,
I'm driving my buddy's car.
This is how I'm going to fucking defend myself.
That I was on a radio station that was actually playing this and I was just sort
of clicking the,
uh,
the preprogram radios,
fucking whatever.
You know what I'm saying?
And I'm hot.
I feel like shit.
Cut me some slack this week.
So anyways,
this song comes on and this,
this Carrie Underwood chick is sitting there singing this song going to rack now
he's probably slowed dancing by hand with the frat now.
And she's singing about her boyfriend.
I got the lyrics right here.
Right now.
He's probably buying her some fruity little drink cause she can't shoot whiskey
right now.
He's probably up behind her with the pool stick showing her how to shoot a
combo.
Yeah.
And then they go into the chorus and she goes and he don't know,
um,
that I dug my keys into the side of his pretty little souped up four wheel
drive,
carved my name into his leather seats.
I took a Louisville slugger to both headlights,
slashed a hole and all four tires.
And all I could think was,
why don't you just break up with them yet?
Dumb cunt.
You know what I mean?
What are you going to do?
You're going to do all this shit.
Then he's going to get mad and then what you're going to make up after five days
and then you're going to blow him again.
I hate this fucking song and I'm going to tell you why,
because it's,
I,
I'm pretty sure it's a hit.
It's on the radio,
right?
Uh,
I dunno.
And what I love about this is people will listen to this song and they won't
even question the rationale of what the fuck someone's doing in there.
Because so many people in life,
myself included,
you,
you play it.
You're like powerless in life.
You just play the powerless card,
you know,
just get out of the fucking relationship.
I fucking hate this song and this is one of these songs too.
We're fucking women all get together and they started saying,
Hey,
guy,
cat has car.
You're all a bunch of dumb cunts.
Okay,
you're fucking stupid.
Just break up with the guy.
Okay.
Just break up with them.
Not even to mention the fact that now you're going out there and you're,
you're,
you're doing damage.
I don't know.
Is that a felon?
That's not a felony.
I don't know what it is,
but it's just a classic thing where a woman would listen to that song and at no
point would she ever think may,
maybe I could get arrested for this.
I am damaging somebody's property.
No,
you got to fucking vagina.
You can just go out and broad day light.
You don't even have to wear a fucking mask.
Do you know what I would have to do if I wanted to go out and go fuck up
somebody's car?
I would have to wait for the,
first of all,
I'd have to make sure I had an alibi.
It'd be like I was killing somebody.
I had to make sure somebody could cover for me and say that I was fucking
somewhere.
Right.
I had to put it on some God damn cat suit and a fucking a mask.
Right?
Like I'm in that dead presidents movie and all I would able to get,
I'd be able to get off one quick hit,
right?
One quick hit.
Let's,
I want to start carving it up like a pussy.
Right.
But if I,
if I really was going to go out there and smash somebody headlights,
I could hit one and the second the car alarm goes off,
I have to fucking take off and then run home,
get out of my little fucking fucking a little cat suit and then try to put on my
pajamas.
So when the cops show up,
because you know they're going to find some sort of fucking fingerprint,
I gotta Act like I'm not out of breath.
Like I actually have been sitting there for fucking eight hours watching TV.
I don't know.
I just,
I can't stand,
you know,
it just reminds me of when that movie,
a fatal attraction came out.
Right.
And the amount of women who would just sit there and you see that movie?
Huh?
Yeah.
That's what you get.
You get,
you know,
this no thought of like this bitch put a rabbit in,
in,
in boiling water does not have that.
Women are there.
They're out of their fucking minds.
But that's not even the point of this.
My point of the Carrie Underwood song,
it actually made me feel like a loser because the amount of fucking times,
I mean I haven't gone out and fucked up somebody's car,
but the amount of times you don't,
what does that song is?
That song?
It's a powerless song.
That's what the fuck it is.
And I went to the whole lyrics to see if she breaks up with them in the end and
there's sort of an ambiguous line in the end where she goes,
uh,
because the next time he cheats,
oh,
you know,
it won't be on me.
So that's sort of ambiguous because it could mean because I broke up with them
or it could be because he doesn't want to get his truck fucked up.
So I dunno.
You know,
I,
I just,
I just fucking annoys me.
That song just annoyed the shit out of me
on,
on both levels.
Well,
you got somebody,
it's like,
just break up with the guy
and your solution is,
you know,
something,
if a girl ever fucking cheated on me that,
that I would break up with them.
I'm not saying I wouldn't flip out and I give him a good fucking trashing
verbally,
but I would never go and like,
uh,
you know,
throw all their clothes out in the front lawn and Burnham.
Okay.
You know,
why wouldn't I do that?
I don't know.
I don't know why.
I think a lot of it has to do because I'd be fucking worried I'd get arrested
for damaging property.
Why do women have an exemption from damaging property?
I don't understand it.
Of a woman sat there smashing up somebody's car and broad daylight because the
guy cheated on him.
People would be laughing.
I would be laughing everyone.
It's,
it's a comedy.
It's just hilarious.
But if the exact same scenario was going down in a guy,
did it [inaudible] be the classic,
you know,
the cops come and they put you in that little,
you get tasered and they mush your face into the fucking pavement.
I Dunno,
I get it.
Women have carry a kid around and that God damn stomach for nine months,
but I don't think that gives you the right to go out and tax somebody for Arrow.
I really don't.
You know,
so why don't you guys just fucking relax.
All right.
You a bunch of God damn psychos.
You know,
with your,
I'm on my period excuse.
So three weeks a month,
you're Outta your fucking mind.
I think if a girl goes,
even if you were cheating on a girl on a woman,
right?
And she fucks up your car,
I really think you ought to be able to go up to her and give her a nice fucking
two piece combination to the Goddamn fucking cabbage.
What do you think about that?
Right?
Just fucking,
just hook off on that fucking
okay.
Hair teased head,
a lettuce on the top of her fucking shoulders.
Right?
What would you go with?
I'm really gonna alienate a lot of my thoughts on this
and I want you to know that most of this is not me advocating punching a woman
in the face.
Most of this is,
I can't fucking sit in this stupid hotel room anymore.
I can't fucking do it.
I've had the God damn
okay.
Do not disturb light on for like four days.
They probably think I overdosed in here.
I'm really big on that.
Don't clean up the room.
Beat it.
You know,
he had to come in and every three days and change the sheets like I'm royalty.
I changed the sheets like fucking once every three weeks.
Maybe that's only if that's only if they are white and I could tell how filthy
they are.
That's right.
Wrinkle your nose up.
You fucking pump is broads.
That's how I live my life.
Um,
Jesus.
Why am I attacking women?
I don't know why.
What was I talking about?
Oh yeah.
If you,
if you could punch a woman in a face,
you allowed to punches,
what would you go with?
Okay.
Would you go classic?
Would you set up the overhand right with the jab?
Would you actually waste a jet?
You know,
waste a jab?
Would you go,
this is just evil.
All right,
I got to get off this fucking subject.
I know that song just annoyed me.
Um,
I hate those fucking songs when women just,
just openly talk about how they're going to go out and destroy a guy's fucking
property rather than break up with them,
you know,
and it's considered some sort of justification,
rather than looking inward going,
you know,
maybe I'm a bad judge of character.
Okay.
What sort of qualities of [inaudible] am I looking for in somebody?
And I'll date that.
I mean,
it didn't,
the fact that the guy had a souped up four wheel drive truck,
didn't that,
give it a go within that?
Give it away on any fucking level,
Huh?
I mean,
souped up four wheel drive truck.
Carrie Underwood.
You dumb fucking,
what else did he have?
Huh?
Uh,
uh,
a fucking earring hanging down with a lightning bolt on the side of it to have
this fucking song sticks.
Okay?
This is one of the,
you know why I hate this sign this,
and I'm going to do my whole podcast on this fucking song.
This is going to be one of those fucking songs when I'm the on the road and I'm
hating my life,
you know,
and I just don't want to go back to the hotel room and be lonely and I'm going
to go out to a bar and that song's going to come on.
It's fucking four fucking twats with their ear piercing.
I'm singing and I'm drunk.
High pitched voices are going to start singing every fucking word of that song.
Liked it.
They liked these fucking cunt bad asses.
Ah,
okay.
And I'm done.
All right.
I'm done with that.
I'm done with that fucking Oh Jesus Christ,
that fucking song.
Nope.
Hey,
what's going on?
It is a bill burr and this is the Monday morning podcast for Monday.
Uh,
what is it?
March 1st,
2009,
uh,
in like a lamb out like a lion.
I ate all that old fucking crap.
They always talk about,
you know,
I've got to look at some fucking groundhog and the,
what are they going to let that shit go,
you know?
Yeah.
I have the most shows.
It's fucking left ball.
Then it's going to rain for the next nine Dars JJ there.
If he's going to dress up in a top hat,
like it's the fucking old days.
You know what I mean?
Some people are just so fucking married.
It's disgusting that they,
they,
they just,
that's all just repressed like sexual energy,
you know,
they've been banging this same broad until her fucking uterus dried out,
you know?
Yeah.
So now they got to go out and they got a dress like fucking JP Morgan waiting
for some road to stick his fucking head out.
And then they got,
you know,
and if you're not familiar with the expression,
they have a,
what is it in like a lamb out like a lion and a lamb out.
Like,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
It means,
you know,
if it starts off good,
it's going to end bad.
If it starts off bad,
it's going to end a good,
that's how that would go.
I am completely not even fucking prepared for this podcast.
Usually I wait until about 45 minutes in and I let you guys figure it out that
the podcast is going to suck for this week.
But I'm going to give you a warning,
almost like,
have you ever see like when a movie's coming out and they say,
uh,
this film has yet to be rated?
That means usually that means it sucks so bad.
We're trying to keep it away from the critics.
So,
uh,
by the time you figure out it sucks,
you're going to be looking at your date.
Like,
oh,
I have to look good.
You know,
I saw the trailer,
we all could it be bad?
Will Smith is in it,
you know,
he's playing some homeless guys,
even in the world.
Um,
yeah,
this podcast is going to suck.
Um,
I just got back from,
uh,
I was in Houston,
Texas and,
uh,
I was so good in Texas and I don't mean comedically.
I mean as a person that,
um,
I was just mind numbingly boring fucking,
you know,
I'm not drinking no internet porn.
It,
you can't do it.
It's impossible.
No,
there's never an expression out there that says beware of the man that has no
vice isn't there?
Hmm.
Can I just ask you that?
Can I just fucking throw that out there?
You know what?
This is why this sucks right now because I'm actually fucking trying to pull
something up right now that I have to play because yesterday was probably the
biggest fucking hockey game in the United States.
Um,
yeah,
probably since,
uh,
1980.
That's what they're saying.
I don't want to use that hack thing doable.
It'll knock old.
Yes.
I don't want to do that.
But it was fucking huge.
Every that we,
75% of Canada they were estimating was watching the gold medal game.
And for all you Americans,
uh,
you actually not Americans,
all,
you,
you people from the United States,
the u s has a hockey team now called team USA and a every four years they play
in the Olympics and a,
we made it to the final round for the gold medal and that game was yesterday.
I know it's a little obnoxious,
but that's how I felt in Houston.
If 75% of the people were watching it and Canada,
I don't think there was more than 75 people watching it and fucking Houston.
They just completely didn't give a shit.
I went down,
this is base basically.
I don't want to ruin it for you,
but a Canada one,
um,
they just played a better game.
I think that they were a better team.
Uh,
yesterday,
I don't know what they did,
figured out their lines,
but it was night and day since we,
uh,
beat him the week before how they looked,
they looked awesome.
I definitely thought they were a better team.
And what I liked was nobody really choked.
There wasn't any bullshit fucking calls.
Um,
I'll fuck you.
Canada.
What the offsite thing.
You guys got enough penalty.
Shut the fuck up.
I want to hear it.
You won the game.
Um,
but that play was offsite and we did get a goal,
but you know what I'm saying?
But it was pretty much,
it was,
it was free of that and it went into overtime.
And uh,
I so wanted the United States to win because,
uh,
obviously I'm a huge,
it was on two levels.
Obviously I'm a huge hockey fan,
but then secondly,
the level with which Canada gives a shit,
it is very few times that
you get a chance to devastate an entire nation and it doesn't involve dropping
bombs on them.
You know,
like if we want that hockey game,
um,
I dunno what they would have been doing.
Those people would've been slitting their wrists up there and their rig loose.
Sorry.
Just had to throw some ignorant American shit out there.
Like,
you guys are fucking smart up there smoking his cigarettes,
sitting in a fucking,
Tim Horton's eaten another fucking doughnut.
What you think?
I never been to Calgary.
You never think you'd have a thought.
I took that fucking highway up to Edmonton.
Pass all those fucking cows in the oil wells.
Fucking guys,
everybody's acting like Dick Cosmopolitan,
all worldly.
Even these days,
I'm getting tired of it.
I'm tired of listening to the fucking hype about how fucking stupid Americans
are.
People who misstates here,
not North Americans in general.
Just people from the fucking states.
And then you travel and you run into the exact same shithead that you are with a
different accent.
All right?
Get over your fucking cells.
But you know,
I gotta give it up.
You got to give it up.
Uh,
they won the fucking game.
So I figured I'd find the gayest
version.
National Anthem.
I think this was a,
I don't know if this was old town or if this was incent.
Who did this one?
This is a tribute to Canada.
Our friends up north,
never harmed to fly.
Never started a war.
Like to pretend you're from Paris,
right?
Stop blaming the east.
That arrogance goes right across the country.
Stopped with the arm down to Earth.
Cause I'm from Winnipeg.
I'm not buying it all.
You guys,
you look down on us.
Okay.
I can even listen to the rest I got,
I got to leave it.
You won the fucking gold medal.
Go ahead.
I bet you guys are tearing up up there right now.
Aren't you
crying into your fucking,
I dunno what some sort of winter garb.
It's any worse than acapella singing.
What is the worst mimes are acappella I think,
I think acappella lease.
You can hear him.
Him.
What's the deal?
Yeah.
Right.
Sons of bitches you want again,
but by the skinny of teeth,
congratulations.
You fucks.
It's a hell of a game.
Does a hell of a Goddamn game.
You know,
the best part was was uh,
the United States.
For those of you in America who didn't fucking watch it.
Uh,
Zach per receipt.
Where the fuck you say his last name is?
He a fucking tied it up with 20 seconds left and 75% of Canada collectively shit
their pants.
And I was like,
oh my God,
it's going to happen now that they soiled themselves,
uh,
you know,
they just fucking annoy me.
They're cocky fans annoy me every fucking time it would
come down,
right?
Anytime the American is doing anything good,
there'd always be that fucking idiot wrapped in the the America of the fucking
Canadian flag gesturing at the fucking ice.
Like the ref missed something.
That's what I don't like about Canadians when it comes to hockey,
is their fucking,
you know,
this is our game.
Did we get pissed when the Blue Jays won the fucking world series?
I made me a little bit.
That was a no,
I don't.
Fuck,
I don't remember.
You know what I did realize that the fucking Stanley Cup has not been in Canada
since 1993 you know,
so maybe that's why they went so crazy.
Hey,
what the fuck did they do?
Their metals,
by the way,
I kind of tapped out in the last couple of Olympics.
It,
you still look cool and you still look like an Oreo cookie,
but it was made out of gold.
It had the same sort of engraving,
right?
Had to like the Olympic sign and now it looks like you took the metal and you
put it on the fucking railroad tracks.
Somebody ran over it.
You know what I mean?
I don't know what have I'm fucking around.
Congratulations.
A,
that was a great game.
It was great for hockey,
but it was definitely a,
all you guys out there listen to me talk shit,
you know,
and enjoying Peyton Manning,
losing the Super Bowl fucking up and all that.
The Karma came back around.
I was devastated all by myself out in Houston.
And uh,
but it was,
it was still great man.
And you know,
I,
I did make fun of Michael Wilbon saying when he said,
ah,
this is the best hockey out there.
I got to admit,
I got to admit without the,
uh,
without the fighting.
Um,
the,
uh,
I don't know.
Do you guys like no touch icing,
automatic icing?
I liked a lot of it.
I got to admit,
I kind of liked the PG version of hockey.
It was kind of Nice.
This is sacrilegious to be saying this,
but I kind of,
uh,
kind of enjoyed it.
You know,
to be great if a couple of goons would make it to the fucking the Olympic squad,
you just so good.
They put you on there.
You just have like,
you know George Lorac verse.
Uh,
I dunno who's the other big heavyweight,
that fucking,
who's that big goon on,
on uh,
Minnesota with that weird last name that has like three letter bs and an n in it
or some shit.
I don't fucking know.
Anyways,
let's plow ahead with the podcast.
This is the Monday morning podcast from Monday,
March 1st,
uh,
that aunties duel and um,
yeah,
I had a hell of a fucking weekend out there in Houston,
Texas.
I want to thank everybody who came out to the Improv and um,
I had great shows Friday night that led into Saturday night and Saturday night.
I think I might've had two of the best shows I've had in recent memory.
Um,
they were just a,
everything sort of clicked.
I kind of,
I was sitting in this restaurant,
um,
eh,
this is,
this is how clean living I am.
Okay.
It's right before 7:00 AM I having a salad with fucking a chicken breast in it,
right.
I got my laptop,
I'm typing out this fucking script,
finishing it up,
drinking a glass of water,
getting the shit out of the way.
And I just remember like,
just having this feeling like this,
this is what Tony Robbins does that you know,
and that's how he has that fucking psycho.
Terminally happy fucking smile on his face,
you know?
And um,
I don't know.
I realized some shit in that moment.
I brought it to stage,
I start a riff and the whole fucking thing worked and I recorded it.
But
beautiful thing about the universe is when you hit something great happens,
something else has to balance it out.
Like I get to see Peyton manning fuck up the Superbowl and thus make me feel
vindicated.
And then two weeks later,
a crushing fucking overtime loss.
It wasn't crushing cause they used,
they used to beat us by fucking,
these will be just like seven to one.
All right,
you got to admit,
okay,
you Canada fucks.
Remember that back in the day it was a joke.
Our hockey was the joke.
First of all,
90% of the people in the league were all from Canada.
Granted,
they were only six fucking teams,
but still,
um,
and you guys used to crush us and now we're breathing down your neck and a,
you better enjoy that gold medal because I've got a feeling that's the last one
you're going to be fucking having for a while.
How do you like that?
Huh?
Now you wait till fucking next year buddy.
Now can you guys handle that shit talking?
All right.
Anyways,
so twice this weekend I had incidents with people in the crowd.
Um,
and both of them were women.
And A,
I'm the first to tell you that I do have fucking issues with women,
but the,
uh,
the first night,
um,
I was on stage and there was this woman right down.
I don't know if it's stage left to stage right from where I'm fucking added
stage left.
All right?
So I think that's the proper terminology.
Why the fuck do you guys need to know stage left stage,
right?
You're in the crowd.
You know,
I go down to midas.
Do I need to know a fucking wrench they're going to use,
I don't need.
Okay,
so stage left or right.
I'm looking down and,
uh,
this fucking girl is,
she's,
you know,
she's talking,
continue on with my jokes.
They looked down,
she still talking.
So finally I say,
hey,
it is sweet tits.
Why don't you,
uh,
what's the problem?
What are you talking about?
And then she does the usual,
ah Ha.
You know,
I wouldn't say she was attractive.
If she was in from a small town,
she'd be a Hottie,
you know,
just out of percentages.
But,
um,
so she did the usual like,
what,
what I have a,
I had no idea what the fuck I'm doing.
You know,
10 minutes later I look back,
she still fucking talking gets a little more heated.
I basically went to her table about six times until I finally told her to shut
the fuck up.
And then,
uh,
I don't really even fucking remember.
Then all of a sudden,
next thing you know,
she's hammered and she's getting kicked out when I got like five minutes left in
my show.
So she threatened to sue the place and all this type of shit.
Now usually that's the end of the night.
You know,
the whole crowd is fucking clapping as she's leaving because she's been fucking
annoying.
Everybody around them who paid to see the show.
All right.
So,
uh,
usually that's the end of it.
But you know what this psycho did.
She actually sent a letter to the Improv and she tried to pretend that that she
wasn't herself.
She tried to pretend that she was an impartial member of the audience who
completely agreed with her and thought that I was a fucking idiot.
So,
uh,
I want to read you a little bit of this fucking letter here.
Um,
to whom it may concern,
I attended bill burrs first show on Friday the 26th and was utterly appalled by
his performance.
I love comedy.
Oh,
this is what you always have to do whenever you bitch.
Um,
and you're not there in person so they can't see what a radiant human being you
are.
You have to.
Then after you state your bitch,
you then have to fucking show how easy going you are as a human being.
So anyway,
she saw my show.
She was utterly appalled by by my performance,
and then she goes,
I love comedy and I certainly expect there to be rudeness crudity and what can
be offensive topics.
That's what comedy is all about.
It makes it fun.
That being said,
okay,
now she's established how fucking cool and laid back she is back to trashing.
Oh fucking howdy duty.
Here she goes.
That being said,
Bill Bird took it way too far and he was quite unprofessional to say the least
while initially there was indeed quite a lot to laugh at.
Yeah.
That was the part where you were sober,
you fucking lightweight.
That was the beginning of the show when you weren't fucking on your ninth
fucking drink and you were actually paying attention to the show.
So yeah,
initially there was indeed quite a lot to laugh at.
I think as a person is trying to write as if it's medieval times and I should be
like fucking holding this thing like a God damn scroll.
I know that isn't medieval ish,
but she's using,
she's doing that biblical thing.
What?
She's using extra fucking words to try to sound intelligent.
While initially there was indeed quite a lot to laugh at it instead of being,
at first he was funny.
Um,
anyways,
the show ended up,
the show ended up being a complete disappointment.
Okay.
For,
okay.
This is her complaint here for at least 30 minutes.
He blast for me,
God and the name of Jesus Christ.
He outright degraded the Catholic religion.
All right.
Now that's complete bullshit.
I only blast some God,
the name of Jesus Christ and the Catholic religion for about seven minutes.
30 minutes.
What am I fucking George Carlin.
I can't talk about anything but 30 minutes.
Maybe you weren't so fucking hammered.
You'd dumb cunt.
You know,
you'd have a better perception of,
of,
of how much time had elapsed.
Oh Geez.
All right,
let's continue.
Although I'll get this,
this and another thing,
another thing where she's,
she's pulling this move again.
He outright to graded the Catholic religion,
although I do not belong to this religion.
So now he's supposed to be like,
wow,
she's not even part of that religion.
And even she found it offensive.
Have you guys picked up on that?
On Youtube at all?
Like when someone wants to trash Obama,
um,
they'll say like,
Obama is the worst president ever.
And then they'll write and I'm a Democrat,
you know,
like you can prove it either way,
just trying to cut people off the pass before they go,
fuck you,
you fuck newswatch and right wing,
whatever.
You know.
Okay,
women need to shut the fuck up.
And I'm a girl,
that dumb shits.
Okay.
So evidently she was,
she was offended and she's not even,
she's not even Catholic anyway.
She said it was offensive and what he said,
uh,
went on and on again,
while this type of thing should be accept a expected,
he took it way too far and there was a young lady who like I and my friends was
becoming offended.
Yeah.
Of course she was because she's you,
you fucking psycho.
Can you believe that?
She thinks I'm this fucking stupid.
And I know what this point is.
Probably not obvious to you guys,
but wait till I finish the rest of this.
All right.
I'm probably going to sound like some maniac here,
but I don't give a fuck.
I said,
that was a young lady who liked I and my friends was becoming offended and said
a few words instead of few words to someone at our table.
You fucking lying sack a Twat.
Anyways,
uh,
she said,
when he rudely addressed her,
that's when I said,
Hey lady,
I guess lady his route.
Hey Lady,
could you do me a favor and maybe look at the show at some point.
Um,
he said when he rudely addressed her,
she told him that she was Catholic.
That never happened.
He had no apologies or considerations.
Just utter disrespect.
Okay.
First of all,
she never said that out.
She never said she was Catholic.
And if she did,
she said,
it's so quietly that I couldn't hear it.
So how the fuck could this random fucking woman in the crowd here,
what she said,
this fucking thing.
It's going to make me mad again.
All right,
let's continue.
After he finally got off that subject,
his show just got worse.
This is what she's on about her sixth strength.
It appeared to my friends and I that he may have been getting heat from some of
the audience and that he felt uncomfortable.
This may very well be the reason why he continued to pick on the lady,
the lady.
This is why I'm picking on her,
not because I,
and as I'm doing my act,
by the way,
I keep looking down and she's getting some sort of Martini thing that looks like
there's a bear in it.
I don't know what the fuck it was.
It's one of those chick fucking drinks,
you know?
Like what if we took root beer and stuck a fucking roofie in it?
You know,
she was drinking those things.
Okay.
And uh,
so now she goes and this very male,
it goes,
this may very well be the reason why he continued to pick on that lady.
Even at one point telling her to shut the fuck up.
Yeah.
I told you to shut the fuck up because you were talking the entire time you
twat.
Anyways,
this is downright unprofessional.
Who said that summer cannot say a few words to people at their table.
Did you see how obvious this is that this is this the actual fucking woman who
would give a fuck much that you would write three pages.
They were quietly speaking and not making any noise whatsoever.
Oh,
yet you heard her say that she was Catholic on the other side of the stage.
There was another table talking quite a bit more and they were louder due to the
drinks yet he did not pick on them.
Do you want to fucking,
okay.
All right.
Let me just fucking relax here.
This is even funny anymore.
Like I totally lost.
I have,
I've lost the whole humor in this.
This is fucking making me so mad.
They were more disruptive than anything,
although he of course made jokes about it.
All right.
There was this table next to me.
They were also drinking,
but they were more doing that church thing where I would say something funny and
then they were sorta like fucking repeating it so they were a little bit rowdy,
but they were acceptable.
This woman who was fucking out drinking every one at the other table had
basically essentially her fucking back to me to the point that if I fucking
punched her in the back of the head,
I would've got two minutes for boarding pat.
Possibly a fucking game misconduct.
All right.
There's something for you.
Olympic hockey,
fucking people.
Anyways,
let's,
let's continue here.
Actually,
that would be roughing wouldn't it?
Let's say I took the mic stand and I turned it sideways.
I could cross checked her on the fucking neck.
All right,
here we go.
Now we are convinced that his wrong demeanor was due to his discomfort after
realizing that he had offended some of the audience in order to justify himself
and ease any tension coming from the audience member.
He said something along the lines of,
don't listen to me.
I'm just an idiot up here speaking.
Pray for me please.
That was obviously a demonstration of his uneasiness.
That's this is,
this is how drunk she was.
What I was doing was I was,
I was telling people in the crowd that if they were religious that I respected
their religion.
All right.
Okay.
I just had,
I just personally don't buy into it.
Okay.
So I'm only stopping right now to say this because I know some of you,
you get so religious,
you get so into it that you can add,
you get so holy that you can actually commit murder.
Okay.
You know,
God's usually agile tool or you know,
vengeance.
I think that was the line I used.
I said,
okay,
you shouldn't be getting mad at me.
You should pray for me to help me see the light in everyone.
Got a huge fucking laugh at it about it.
Okay.
And this lady is basically us.
She's,
I can't wait to email her back.
I don't know.
I,
I've,
I've flipped flopped a hundred times in my head.
What I was going to say.
Okay.
You know,
I just can't wait to,
uh,
I think I'm just gonna write back something really quickly.
Okay.
Like Ruth,
you actually pretending to not be the dumb drunk bitch in the crowd is one of
the funniest things I've ever read.
Something to that effect.
Basically let her know that I know that it's her and I'll see you next year at
the Improv.
You can't.
Um,
anyways,
I am very supplies surprised at your call.
This is where she tries to um,
yeah.
This is where she tries to get me banned from the club.
I'm very surprised that uh,
your club hosted this comedian.
It was a true disappointment.
I am embarrassed as I was the one who suggested the Improv.
When my friends and I were planning to answering a comedy show,
I do hope that you will consider not this comedian back as he gives your club a
bad name.
If this is a,
this had been my first time to the Improv,
I never would have returned.
You might consider hiring some local talent.
There are several good comedians in the area.
We are good friends with one of them.
If you like his name,
I'll be happy to give it.
Did DPP a bit bit.
All right.
As for the lady who we picked on,
she and her table,
we're unjustifiably asked to leave.
There was no grounds on having them escorted from the show right in the middle
of it.
That's how drunk she was.
She got escorted out 50 minutes into my one hour set and she's like,
she was escorted out in the middle of it.
Do you understand how drunk this one was?
I talked for Jesus about Jesus for 30 minutes.
No,
actually it was seven minutes.
I was escorted out in the middle.
No,
you are actually escorted out 50 minutes into the show when you were on your
fucking six drink.
You're drunk can't,
there were no grounds of on having them escorted from uh,
from the show right in the middle of it.
Again,
they were not being disruptive,
voted at all this,
this,
this impartial person just wants to keep talking about how innocent this fucking
lady is that she never met.
If it hadn't been for bill burr picking on them,
no one would even notice them.
Okay.
The kid you tell.
This is just the,
the fucking drunk argument they had and the crowd and in the car on the ride
home,
the loud table.
And the other side though is the one that took away attention from his show.
I do understand that it is private property and that anyone can be asked to
leave at any time.
But this was wrong to do.
This is a wrong time to do it.
I personally believe that she should receive an apology from the Improv,
but mostly from bill burr.
That's clearly not my call.
Just the thought.
What a fucking,
uh,
I dunno.
Did I take too long reading that fucking thing.
There you go.
You want to be a standup comedian?
That's what the fuck are you have to deal with?
She's actually like a total fucking control freak.
And what happened that night was she completely lost on all levels.
Yeah.
You know,
it's weird.
You become like a part time psychologist as you're breaking down the crowd as a
comedian.
And she sat at the power position at the table.
The table.
Is that like a fucking,
we'll say like a 30 degree angle coming in stage left.
This is going to get technical.
Alright,
you fucks.
Don't,
don't,
don't leave me here.
She,
you know,
she didn't sit at the chair furthest away.
If you sit furthest away,
everybody you're at the table with has the back of their head to you.
So then when you want to fucking talk,
it's,
it's a difficult time.
What she did was not only did she sit in the first chair,
she sat on the first chair closest to me,
so the,
so all she had to do was turn around.
She had the whole fucking tables attention.
And when she stood up,
when she went to leave her whole table stood up like a bunch of fucking minions.
You know,
like you remember that dude,
he used to carry the fucking umbrella for puffy.
That's how they all got up.
It was pathetic.
And people like that surround themselves with fucking weak people like that
because any normal people,
person,
you know,
think about that.
All you guys listening to right now,
if your,
if your buddy was being a drunk fucking asshole and got booted from the club,
would you get up and leave immediately?
Stand up like the fucking general just got up.
I mean,
I guess maybe you would,
could you be walking?
He's drunk.
Maybe it's going to go fucking walk out in a p on a cop or something.
I guess maybe.
I Dunno.
Anyways,
you know,
before I emailed her back,
what do you guys think I should write back and come up with something clever
other than calling her a cunt like I did.
I think I'm just,
I'm,
I'm going to write back something to the effect that I realized that it was her
and um,
I dunno.
I don't fucking know.
Was that just a big waste of time?
Should I not have been bothered with all of that?
You know,
I dunno.
Dan and I had another incident with another fucking person.
I don't know.
I,
I have issues with,
with a beautiful women.
I really do.
This is actually a bit I want to do on stage and I'll just,
I'll maybe I'll do part of it for you here at bay.
The basic idea,
I just,
I don't respect them on a certain level.
I feel like I had to do something
to achieve in life.
All they had to do was basically they were born beautiful.
This is really not an accomplishment I guess.
You go to the gym,
you stay beautiful past a certain age.
It is an accomplishment I guess.
But you know,
I don't know,
for an order as a guy to get around beautiful women,
you have to accomplish all this shit in life and all they have to do to get to
where the fuck you're at after accomplishing all this shit is basically take a
shower and feather their hair back like Farrah Fawcett and they're in the
fucking VIP.
You know,
I also don't like him because,
uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno if they're smart.
They,
if they're smart,
they're absolutely stunning though.
I have to admit that.
But you know,
if they're,
if they're dumb,
that's like,
it's like he got a Lamborghini.
But you find out it has a four cylinder in,
it won't even worse.
My fucking hybrid.
Did that make any fucking sense?
You know,
they have that one default emotion.
Oh my God.
And they give 58 different reads.
You know,
if they see something cute like a little puppy,
they're like,
oh my God.
Okay.
You know,
if you do something sweet for from,
Oh my God,
yeah.
You know,
you do something that they fucking hate.
Oh my God.
Fucking idiots.
They got three words floating around in there and they're in VIP,
you know,
slapped a fucking spit out of their mouth.
All right,
let's plow ahead here.
This is the Monday morning podcast and,
uh,
oh,
also,
you know,
I don't know why I didn't think to say this.
Um,
I can,
I have a new player.
I've kind of abandoned Lipson already.
Okay.
That was like my rebound girl after I broke up with fucking g cast.
It just didn't work out.
Um,
you know,
like Eddie Murphy and one of the spice girls,
but fortunately I didn't impregnate a luminosity.
Luminosity.
I'm sorry.
Just reading that,
uh,
Lipson,
I'm speaking of that.
I'll let the cat out of the bag.
Um,
this is something I'm trying to do is to actually go on the internet and rather
than becoming,
even even dumber than I really am or is it more dumb?
I don't even know.
I know it's more stupid.
It's not stupid or is it?
I have no fucking idea,
but all I know is,
uh,
I'm trying to figure out basically how not to become more of a shithead online.
And I would really like to start this as a new segment.
Where is,
are there things out there that I can look at?
I know ted.com I love that site even though I haven't been to it in a month.
Ted like Ted kennedy.com minus the rape and alcohol.
Um,
there's one out here called luminosity.com l u m o s,
I t y.com.
And it's basically games for your brain.
And I'm telling you,
man,
it's fucking awesome.
And I cannot even begin to tell you how low I scored on these things.
Uh,
you know,
they got these things,
they got everything.
Literally they got one game called like duck hunting,
right?
And what happens is a duck appears on the screen while simultaneously,
you know,
somewhere in your peripheral vision while simultaneously on the screen a letter
appears.
And then what you have to do is you have to click with a bird was and also
remember the letter.
And then when the,
then they'll give you a series,
like a lineup,
usual suspect of letters.
You got to pick the right letter.
And then it's like wheel of fortune.
Do you got one letter and you're trying to solve the word and it's a name of a
bird.
So you're fucking learning to look at two things at one time process,
both of them.
And you're getting better at wheel of fortune all at the same time and learning
new names of fucking birds that you didn't even know existed.
That's just one fucking game.
Okay?
So if we can get back into the ying and Yang,
the balance of life,
if you want to somehow balance off nine hours of fucking going on to Youporn and
watching people get kicked in the nuts on youtube,
I highly,
I can't recommend this site highly enough.
You could sign up,
you get a free week of games,
luminosity.com l u m o s I t y.com and then it,
you know,
even the membership is not that bad.
But,
um,
I don't know.
I'm not the brightest guy,
but I think I have good common sense and I have a feeling then at about 10 years
after all the how to get fucking a six pack abs books have been written,
somebody is finally going to focus on the brain and start to realize that your
brain,
like you fucking midsection can turn to mush the exact same way.
And like I,
I,
I definitely think my brain is not nearly as sharp as it was 20 years ago.
It's weird because as you get,
you get older,
you know,
that whole thing,
you get older,
you get wiser,
you know,
basically you're learning from fucking up,
but you're not as sharp.
And,
uh,
I dunno,
this is this,
this,
um,
this site was the closest thing to doing like mental pushups and they're cool.
They're fun games,
man.
It taps into the video.
I actually have a new found respect for video games were like,
um,
you know,
I,
I got away from video games because they were just eating up all of my free
time.
The last one I really was grand theft auto part three and a,
it absolutely consumed my life.
And the thing about that game was even after I finished the game,
I had to get the cheats.
I'm going to lie to you.
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It had to cheat,
you know,
um,
when I finally finished everything,
I would still play the game and just go on those rampages.
And I found it to be like a stress relief and uh,
but it,
it was just like too much.
But after it seriously,
you have to play in those games.
I kind of realized that.
Um,
look at me.
I'm too fucking stupid to convey this idea.
Just go to luminosity.com and if anybody else knows any other sites like that or
just something that,
uh,
can give me some mental setups,
I would really like it because I'm,
I'm getting into that stuff.
Like,
I don't know if I told you guys a comedian,
I forget who the fuck it was told me about.
There was some book out there that was saying,
I'm a great exercise to do as if you're like lefthanded is to start doing things
with you that you normally do with your left hand right handed.
All right,
I'm gonna wait for you guys to finish doing the Dick joke there.
Ooh.
Fuck a robot.
Oh,
well wait,
fueling somebody else.
Uh,
you guys fist bumping in your cubicles with that hack joke from fucking make me
laugh in 1977.
Can I continue with my podcast?
Thank you.
Um,
no,
it actually,
I don't know what it does.
It's,
it's somehow it actually makes you more,
uh,
God,
I'm so fucking stupid.
What is the word?
Um,
like say if you were playing guitar,
say if you're,
if you're a left handed guitar,
it's like I am,
it's so pathetic to even call myself a guitar.
Someone who attempts to play guitar,
I play left handed.
If you actually,
if I were actually to fuck around on a right handed guitar and try to learn to
play something,
if I then the the second I went to the lefthanded guitar,
you would actually learn it quicker.
I have no idea why,
which should be obvious at this point because I could barely fucking explain it.
So anyways,
I fly a lot.
It drives me nuts.
I hate flying.
And so what I do when I fly is I actually sit there and I listened to music and
I write the lyrics with my right hand rather than my left hand.
And I've actually gotten like halfway decent at it and a,
at the very least I'm thinking of someday if I'm unfortunate enough to have a
stroke,
you know,
my turnaround time's going to be incredible.
I'll be robbing them out.
It'd be right in fucking letters catching the drool with my opposite hand.
You know,
it's so fucking bad.
Yeah,
that's what it is.
Join me.
But come stroke proof or what have not stroke proof become a,
I dunno.
Cut your rehab costs 50%.
God knows nobody has fucking health insurance anymore.
Could be a good thing.
Right?
Have I said anything funny in the last fucking 19 minutes?
I have no idea.
Somewhere in the middle of that letter I got fucking mad again and all the funny
went out the window.
And I'll tell you the first rule of fucking losing a crowd.
Well I guess no confidence and have a no jokes would be first,
but other that it's just going up there and be in an angry fucking psycho.
Um,
oh,
I want to thank everybody for,
uh,
you know,
last week I talked about women's curling and a,
and by the way,
I totally enjoyed the Olympics.
I love the Winter Olympics and I'm sick of people shitting on him.
All these late night talk show hosts talking about Hulu.
They're fucking boring.
Really?
Why don't you go do another lame monologue about fucking that girl who got eaten
by a fucking whale.
Give me your take coming out there wearing a suit.
Like you have a fucking war one before you had the Goddamn show.
Sorry.
You know I get heated when people make fun of the Olympics.
You know,
I was talking about how hot the fucking women of curling were.
A little bit of phlegm left.
Um,
and somebody said,
uh,
was actually saying like,
I was trying to figure out why I was finding these fucking women so attractive
other than the obvious that they were good looking women.
This guy actually said,
hey,
bill,
uh,
beside the obvious hot women vigorously scrubbing the floor,
I really set that up bad.
He's saying,
this is why men find women curlers attractive.
I just blew that joke.
He said,
besides the obvious hot women vigorously scrubbing the floor.
I have,
dude,
I,
you so deserved a huge laugh on that and I just fucked you out of it.
I'm sorry about that.
Um,
anyways,
he says,
I have figured out why we love watching this so much.
When they release that stone,
the way they let it slide out of their hand is reminiscent of the way a skill
for woman releases your cock after delivering a massive hand job.
First of all,
I hope you're a surfer cause that's the only reason why to the massive hand job,
um,
fucking massive hand job.
Or maybe you just have a fucking bit,
oh,
maybe I'll just,
you have a fat cock.
I Dunno.
So anyway,
she goes,
uh,
they don't drop it.
Don't push it.
Just let it slide out naturally as they go to sleep with my boxes around my
ankles.
Oh,
I forgot.
That was creepy.
I know I read it.
I was supposed to just read the beginning joke cause I thought the joke was
fucking great.
I forgot the fucking picture and his
guys with those fucking insect looking legs.
Some guy's legs like insects with that fucking hair all over him.
Skinny fucking legs were a mess.
Fucking mess.
I'm like praying mantis legs.
Anyways,
I'm a long time ago.
I talked about unacceptable.
This is when,
you know,
the podcast sucks on,
I'm just plowing from fucking topic to topic and there's just no sort of a no
segue other than dead silence.
Um,
let's go to youtube videos for the week.
Let's,
let's,
let's go over here.
You know,
I feel like the fucking dumb fuck on,
uh,
on like jeopardy when there's like five difficult topics in one easy ones,
you know,
great scientist,
architecture,
medieval,
whatever.
And let's go,
let's go with the
developments in a lawn chair for 100.
That's not even an easy as it up till five.
I'm just too dumb.
I'm too fucking dumb.
Whatever.
You know what?
I played those brain games.
I'm too stupid this week.
Here's a youtube video to look up.
Look up.
Do Schoff,
d o u c h e o f f a Douche off.
Maybe you'll find that humorous.
I can't remember if I did.
I think I did.
I believe I did because I left it there.
Uh,
bad wedding stories.
This is another topic.
Who the fuck do I sound like I'm doing right now?
Yeah.
Did somebody to do a Bob Dole impression.
Lay out a fucking the worst.
Can I tap out at this fucking point 37 minutes in a bad wedding stories.
Um,
hey bill,
I haven't listened to your podcast since the beginning.
Decided it was about time I emailed you and told you how much I enjoy it.
Thank you very much.
Uh,
the okay,
let's get to the,
uh,
to get to the marriage thing.
Um,
okay.
I got to marriage story when I was 23,
I was dating a girl and she got pregnant.
Oh Dude.
Okay.
Uh,
so we decided to get married.
Okay.
Stupid.
Fucking move number two,
even though a month before this I was thinking about dumping her ass.
Stupid mistake number three.
Actually that was the smart move.
That was,
that was the three card Monte right there.
Don't knock her up.
Don't fucking merrier.
Wait,
knock her up.
Mary,
her dumper ass.
You know which one had the marble?
You fucked up.
All right,
so all the plans are made,
our families meet each other.
Okay.
Just cause I,
you know,
had to do that stupid three card Monte joke in a desperate attempt to try to be
remotely funny at this point.
You know,
it was,
I have a blue wind screen this week.
I'm going to blow that.
I'm going to,
I'm going to blame it on that one.
You know,
my fucking dog ate the orange one,
so I'm going to blame it on the blue wind screen.
Anyway.
So basically,
sky's 23 years old.
He knocks up this fucking girl.
He decides to get married even though he,
he thought about dumping our month before.
So anyways,
so all the plans are made.
Um,
families meet each other,
invitations are sent out,
all that bullshit.
So three days before the wedding,
I'm watching some stupid movie where this guy tells his other guy that his dad
told him before his wedding,
it's never too late to change your mind,
to which his friends says,
but you're not married.
And I guess it is.
That's a lap.
So anyways,
uh,
so taking this as a sign from God that I just happened to be watching this
movie.
I canceled a wedding.
Great.
Fucking move.
All right.
Which just suffice to say,
brought a shitstorm into my life.
The worst part is that I actually felt so bad.
I married the chick three months later.
Oh Dude,
you were out.
You were fucking out.
So basically I was a pussy.
Yeah.
But two,
that's a hard thing.
You were dealing with a lot of shit at 23.
Your parents were crying.
She was knocked up.
Yeah.
I wouldn't say you were pushing,
you gave into peer pressure anyways,
we were married for seven years with every year being worse than the year
before.
So we're divorced,
so we're divorced now.
So I guess I should have gone with my gut to wrap this up,
I got a little gripe with,
with chicks.
My ex used to ask me when the marriage was going down,
if I could go back,
would I not meet her?
Which I would say,
fuck yeah,
I would avoid you like the plague.
Which she would say,
uh,
W at which point she would say,
but you wouldn't have our two kids,
don't you love them?
And then he would say,
yeah,
but then I'd say,
but I,
I would never have met you,
so I would have never had the kids.
So in that scenario,
the kids aren't even a thought.
This of course would lead to a huge fight about my lack of caring,
a moral to the story.
Don't use logic when talking to chicks.
All right?
That's actually not the moral to the story.
What it is,
is you got to think how women think,
you know,
which you know,
if you're lucky,
at some point when you're 90,
you'll know,
you'll understand 10% of what the fuck is going on in that brain.
Um,
basically when she's asking you that,
she was asking that,
I would guess one of two reasons.
One,
she was insecure that,
you know,
you knocked her up and then you married her and you know that you were gonna
marry her.
Then you broke it off and then you fucking married her.
Uh,
believe it or not,
I'm sure that's not how she dreamed of getting married.
She probably dreamed of meeting her soul mate and they were so hopelessly in
love that everyone in the crowd had tears in their eyes for,
they never found a love.
So as great as theirs,
she could have been thinking that.
And she wanted you to reassure her or she probably was just banging you,
you know,
and didn't want to fucking marry you and didn't think that you were the one
either.
And all of a sudden she got knocked up and she probably sitting there looking at
the Saturday,
your fucking head.
One morning you're eating pancakes,
trying to find where in the world she loves you.
You know,
on what fucking level.
just watching your temples going in and out as you're chewing,
just fighting that fucking urge to slam a toaster over your fucking head.
You know,
just wondering how to hell that I ended up with this fucking guy.
Why did I say Yes to this guy?
Why did I let him fucking drop a fucking load in me?
What is wrong with me?
And just trying to make the fact that you had these two kids justice justice
enough,
you know,
that's what the fuck was probably going on.
But,
uh,
I dunno,
dude,
you didn't really talk about how much of a nightmare the wedding was that that
was the meat of the story there.
I think you had the beginning and the end,
but what are you thinking is she's coming down the aisle?
What is your family thinking?
You're knocked her up and then you dumped her and yet you're like,
oh,
fuck it.
I'll marry or anyways,
and you're only 23.
They know you don't want to do it.
Yeah.
Those weren't tears of joy,
my friend,
you know,
what are you thinking is you're up there,
was your Cumber Bun like wringing wet with flop sweat as she was standing up?
I can't imagine that.
Ah,
has anybody ever just ran out the side door?
Because I could definitely see like,
oh my God,
I don't know what to say.
How do I get out of this shit?
And then just in a panic when they started,
Eh,
dead,
turn around and look at where is she?
Oh,
why the fuck didn't I have some wedding music underneath?
This would've would've been hilarious if I fucking prepared.
You know,
you're looking for the bitch,
where the fuck is he?
And then she comes around the corner and you're trying to make yourself lover
and she comes around the corner and you just see that fucking face and you see
those eyebrows at,
you know,
we're going to be touching by the time she's 40 and you just fucking run out the
side door in those cheap tuxedo bowling shoes
and you know what I mean?
And you're,
it's such a fucking panic,
you know,
there's no way,
okay
that you're going to be able to get your car keys out in time,
get them into the door,
open the door,
lock the door and get in there.
And it's like people are going to be coming out,
running out of the church like some fucking Zombie movie as you're trying to get
your car started.
I mean the move there is you,
if anybody does that,
don't go to your car.
You keep running.
Okay.
Most people get married in the suburbs,
so headed head for a wooded area.
All right?
Go Online.
Learn how to turn your fucking cumber bun and do a tent.
Hang out there for a couple of days.
Let Shit cool off.
Grow a beard,
come back to town,
get some provisions that point you'll be so fucking filthy.
He just another homeless guy wearing a suit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Just let her forget all about you.
Then maybe they'll think that you're mentally ill and then uh,
you know,
one day you just show up on your mother's front steps and she faints.
Her Dad catches you in,
punches you in the face.
Cause he's a former marine.
You know,
haven't we all seen this movie?
I'm trying to say,
run out the fucking door.
Run out the fucking door if you're in that situation,
if you're in that situation.
All right.
Uh,
Bill,
longtime listener,
first time writer.
I got a winning story to tell you.
I'm 23 years old now.
The 23 year old.
I've been a,
here's one for you.
Uh,
don't go to a wedding or getting married at 23.
They all seem to have bad stories.
Um,
I've been to a few weddings and let me start by saying in this story,
it wasn't actually a wedding I witnessed.
It was a wicking,
a Wiccan hand fastening.
Okay.
Now they'll fit.
For those of you not familiar with the wicked religion,
uh,
I just want to state at this point,
neither of my,
um,
I can't remember if that's the one that actually has all those pagan symbols
that,
you know,
the Catholic Church then said that they were devil signs according to the,
uh,
fucking Rosetta Stone or whatever that fucking movie was.
I read the book too.
What the fuck is the name of that Davinci Code?
Um,
whatever it was called,
a Wiccan hand.
Fascinating.
And I know that because my sister didn't invite people to our wedding,
she invited them to her hand.
Fascinating.
That's why he knew it was a Wiccan hand fascinate and not a wedding.
Because she said,
I'd like to invite you to my hand.
Fascinating.
Jesus Christ.
Um,
he said,
if you're 41,
you still don't know when a hand fascinating is congratulations.
Thank you.
Because I didn't,
so anyways,
he goes,
I'm 17 at the time,
my sister's 23 or 24.
We both still live with our parents or boyfriend and unemployed,
alcoholic living off money.
His mom left him when she died.
Ah,
there you go ladies.
There you go.
You don't have to settle for less when there's guys like him out there.
Um,
anyways,
um,
the fuck am I,
why didn't I make this tight?
Bigger.
Jesus.
What a flop this podcast is.
So anyways,
so this fucking alcoholic was over for dinner one night.
He tapped his fork on the glass a few times to get everyone's attention.
We were three feet from him and immediately my stomach knotted up because I knew
this moron was about to say something stupid.
You got,
I got to meet you.
You guys.
It's fucking funny writers,
man.
Some really talented people.
Listen to this fucking podcast.
You guys write better than I do.
Anyways,
basically he announced his engagement to my sister in front of my mom and dad
pulled out to onyx rings and they put them on each other's middle fingers.
You know,
I went to the Onyx Strip club and now Houston last night.
How funny is that?
Anyways,
it was dead silent and um,
the look of a repressed horror on my mom's face was unmistakable.
It was so awkward.
So I just started clapping going Yay.
Quietly,
because nobody else joined in.
Oh,
that's great.
Is that your role in the family?
You're the person who always tries to make it better.
God bless Ya.
Anyways,
it was just dead silence and my sister and her boyfriend kissing each other like
everything was fine.
A few months later I found out they were financing those rings and going into
payments on them.
Every week.
My sister's collecting child support and neither of them have a job and they are
financing onyx hand fastening rinks.
Jesus Christ,
Jesus Christ.
I can't believe there's more to this story.
All right,
here we go.
Fucking knee deep.
I got to go the rest of the way.
All right.
Anyway,
so I finally,
uh,
it finally gets to their hand fastening day and they're doing the ceremony right
on Newport beach.
It's in the middle of the day on a,
on Sunday in the summer,
they didn't have,
oh,
they didn't reserve a piece of beach or anything.
They just showed up and go,
hey,
let's have the wedding here.
Um,
the family we had,
oh fuck.
I got to sit close to the damn screen.
I can't read anymore.
The family we have near the beach mostly all showed up.
All the people who lived near the beach mostly showed all,
oh,
there were about 30 or 40 of us.
None of us,
none of us are dressed in beach close.
Half of them are in suits and dresses.
There are no chairs.
There's not even an altar.
Everybody's just standing around hot and they can't sit down because there's no
chairs and they don't,
they don't want to ruin their clothes.
My sister shows up in an all black gown with the veil.
The boyfriend is wearing like a Tux with his face painted like one of the
misfits,
kind of like a skeleton face.
Jesus Christ.
It sounds like the episode of the office.
Anyways,
they don't do any traditional wedding stuff.
They just go right up front of the crowd with their Wiccan priest or whatever.
The Wiccan priest is basically just a friend of theirs.
He reads a bunch of a bunch of stuff from a book in some other language,
my sister and the boyfriend or responding in some of their language.
Nobody has any idea what's going on.
Then all of a sudden,
the boyfriend pulls out this crazy looking knife with a what?
A hilt.
I don't know what that is.
Uses it to cut my sister's veil.
Then pokes the end of it into his finger until he's bleeding.
He sticks the knife into the sand and wraps his bloody hand around my sister's
neck while they kiss the stone.
Hippie priest holds up his book and said something loud in that different
language.
I assume it was equivalent equivalent of I now pronounce you husband and wife.
I'm sure being comedian.
You've heard the sound of 50 people gasping simultaneously.
Family members in suits and dresses are just walking away at this point.
A lifeguard saw what the boyfriend did with the knife called the cop and the day
ended prematurely with him getting cuffed and driven away in a police cruiser.
Jesus Christ.
Anyways,
thanks for the podcast.
I really enjoy it.
Jesus Christ.
How about a fucking round of applause for that story?
All right.
I think I have to read up on the a Wiccan religion.
You know,
one thing I did like about that,
I did like the fact that they just showed up and just decided to have a wedding
and they avoided all those other costs.
Um,
cause I wanted to say halfway through that like,
you know,
they didn't have,
they didn't reserve that piece of the beach or anything and I was thinking like,
well he never had to back in the day.
You know what I mean?
You just fucking had a wedding.
There was,
it wasn't like nine zillion fucking dollars.
Didn't matter where you were,
but I guess you have to do that now because there's nine zillion people and
bankers run the
fucking world.
Hey,
speaking of that,
did you get,
somebody sent me an email the other day,
evidently Europe elected a president.
Do you hear that?
Europe elected a president,
not England,
not France,
Europe.
The entire continent now has a fucking president,
has one guy in charge of all of them.
See that just like those three d TVs that are only a few months away,
that new world daughter is going to be available right down at the best buy
coming,
sewed,
come and fucking soon.
If you go on and read about the,
uh,
the bailout,
rolling stone has a great article and a,
usually I try to stay away from their politics because there's so brutally to
the left.
It's fucking ridiculous.
Um,
you know,
they never trashed Democrats or when they do,
it's so like light hand.
They just doing it just because they trashed of Republicans so bad.
They're trying to show that they're fair and balanced like those other fucking
maniacs.
Um,
Fox News actually has a store now when you go through the airport,
which I think is hilarious.
They sell water and that type of shit.
So,
I dunno,
it's gonna be,
there's gonna be one fucking news channel is going to be one president and one
fucking currency of money and you better do what they say.
Oh I raw.
That's going to be the end of it,
my friends.
Um,
anyways,
if you want to check it out,
it's the,
um,
it's the rolling stone that actually has a Eric Clapton and Jeff Beck on the
cover.
And if you guys are fans of music,
I guess they're going to be doing a tour together,
which is unbelievable.
They used to be big time rivals back in the day and now they're fucking in their
sixties.
They're like,
yeah,
let's get some money for the medication we now need.
And uh,
I guess they're going to be doing a tour and a,
and with that,
um,
I didn't have time,
you know,
cause I,
I got a couple of weird weeks coming up guys.
I've got to tell you this world,
I usually take Sundays off,
so I'm flying home on Sundays and so then I get a good night's sleep and I can
give you a decent podcast.
But,
uh,
this week and this upcoming week one,
I'm going to be at the Improv in San Jose and I am working Thursday,
Friday,
Saturday,
and Sunday.
So I won't be a,
it is a quick flight,
so next weeks will be a good podcast,
but that's why this one was so late today.
So I apologize and I didn't get a chance to recommend any of the music that you
guys have been sending in,
but I'll definitely try to read it next week.
And,
um,
I finally have gotten into Pantera to a sick fucking level.
And,
um,
if you get a chance,
download a vulgar display of power or cowboys from hell.
And um,
I actually used to play in this fucking,
uh,
you know,
garageband and,
uh,
my brothers and some of their other friends,
she used to get in to thrash and I,
I was never into it.
I was more like into ACDC and John Bonham and trying to get my bass drum is fast
as bottoms,
so I never got a double pedal or any of that shit.
Well,
a few years ago,
I finally got one and listening to cowboys from hell,
I gotta fucking get that down because,
uh,
I dunno,
combination of Vinny Paul and Tim Alexander Brulee make me want to play double
bass and Alex Van Halen.
Those are,
uh,
and I'm actually listening to the lamb of God.
Now,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
You guys sent me that old school fucking hip hop from the late nineties.
I fucking devoured that shit.
And then now I'm going into,
into,
into thrash.
I Dunno.
I like all of it.
I like all of it except country music.
Oh,
speaking of which,
you've seen that stupid song that fucking woman wrote about being a redneck
woman.
How she likes being a redneck woman,
a k if you guys,
if you got crushed in this economy,
if you want to get rich quick scheme,
just write an anthem that celebrates being a complete fucking moron.
And um,
and,
and you basically tell people that underachieving in life is a good thing and
people will absolutely love it.
Like just sing those stupid songs were like,
God,
Ryan,
I have a beer.
And sit in my own to where then fucking eat a steak and visit all the countries
because whales never going to be better than being rob here with my book and
Banjo and a bear ran a tennis fit.
All right.
Something like that.
It has to rhyme,
you know,
and then you got to throw the fucking flag and then I'll tell you right now,
if,
if country musicians ever did stand up,
they would be the fucking worst comedian.
They would be the exact kind of comedian.
I hate the one that panders to the crowd,
which is what,
you know,
the ones that fucking sit there and they look at this guy,
he knows what I'm talking about.
Right back me up ladies.
You know?
Well it is crowded because looking crowd and I give yourselves a round of
applause for coming out tonight.
God always loved coming out is one of my favorite cities.
You know,
they say that every town.
So it doesn't fucking mean anything.
That's what country singers alike a lot of them fucking singing those songs
about supporting the troops.
I mean,
I mean you fucking pussy.
Take a chance.
You know,
you write a song support in the fucking troops light,
like any critic out there is now going to say like,
well,
you know,
it's kind of hacky chord progressions.
I've heard that before.
They can't because you're insulated by fucking putting our troops in front of
you.
You fucking pussy
and bullying.
I liked bear in ice cream.
If you don't get the fuck out country.
I like,
I like beer and ice cream too.
You know he's got everything in there,
but saying we shouldn't fucking punch babies.
Don't punch babies and don't step on the American flag.
And if you do,
I'm going to punch you in the face.
Everybody.
All right.
Thanks for listening to this week.
Sorry.
It was so disjointed and fucked up,
but that's what you get when it's free,
Huh?
Oh,
little Catholic guilt there.
I do it for you.
I did it [inaudible].